be remarkable
if you want to have success in business
you have to get people to want to talk
about your company
you don't have the money to spend on
huge ads that go on on the super bowl on
tv ads radio show ads right you don't
have that budget
you want to have success you need people
to talk about your business and that
comes from being remarkable
think about the word remarkable it means
make a remark about something
why should people make a remark about
your company you have to give them a
reason
if you don't you're dead in the water
you're not going to achieve success with
your company you're going to be an
average or mediocre business as an
example think about what you're wearing
right now okay i'm wearing i have a
sweater on i've got a t-shirt on
underneath i've got a regular shirt on
here i've got some jeans on think about
what you're wearing right now how many
people have you told about what you're
wearing right now how many friends of
yours have you told about the sweater or
shirt that you're wearing right now
how many people have you told about the
company that you bought it from whatever
retailer you bought it from or whatever
online store you bought it from if
you've told people about it then that
company did a great job in being
remarkable there was something special
about them
there was something that made you want
to tell people about them
and for every other piece of clothing
that you have
those companies didn't do a good job if
you can't remember where you bought your
sweater or your shirt if you can't
remember what brand it is
then they didn't do a good job of being
remarkable because you're not gonna go
back you don't even remember where you
bought it you're not gonna go back to
that store you're not gonna tell your
friends to go to that store
you're going to be forgettable so take
out a pen take out a piece of paper and
write down three things that you can do
to be remarkable do something that is
worth making a remark about you need
people to want to come back and tell
their friends about your business
otherwise you're going to continue to
struggle
continue to
try to figure out when am i going to get
my next paycheck you know
it's hard
and it is a big struggle for a lot of
entrepreneurs
and most businesses don't have anything
that is worth sharing
i walk by a lot of businesses every day
on my my day to work and i don't see
anything remarkable
and we're so busy in our day-to-day
lives there's so much going on
that if you want people to take time out
of their schedule to talk about you to
tell their friends about how great you
are you have to give them an outstanding
reason
so that's your homework for the week
think of three things that you can do
write them down
and then start acting on them
to make your business more remarkable to
make people want to make a remark about
your company and tell their friends
if you do that
you'll start having greater success with
your business
belief